باغلبيه ساحقه وابو الاوروبيون لصالح
وصف روسيا بانها دوله راعيه للارهاب وهذا
ما جاء في النص الذي اقر في ستراسبورغ
الهجمات والفضائع المتعمده التي ارتكبها
الاتحاد الروسي ضد السكان المدنيين في
اوكرانيا وتدمير البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
وغيرها من الانتهاكات الجسيمه لحقوق
الانسان والقانون الدولي ترقى الى اعمال
ارهابيه ردت موسكوب غضب على قرار البرلمان
الاوروبي
اقترحوا تصنيف البرلماني الاوروبي راعيا
للحماقه
الخطوه الاوروبيه تعد رمزيه الى حد كبير
ليس لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي اطار عمل قانوني
يدعم ذلك طلبات كيف مرارا المجتمع الدولي
باعلان روسيا دوله رعي للارهاب على خلفيه
غزوها لها ملتهمه موسكو باستهداف المدنيين
من اجل وضع حد لسيادتها القديمه المتمثله
بالارهاب في اوكرانيا وفي انحاء العالم
فمتنعت حتى الان عن ادراج موسكو على
قائمتها وتشمل قائمه وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه حاليا للدول الرعيه للارهاب
اربع دول كوبا وكوريا الشماليه وايران
وسوريا لما يعني حظر الصادرات الدفاعيه